two different quotations from c.s lewis
for if ow now he's going after my toes
stop that um
okay
for if crime and disease are to be
regarded as the same thing it follows
that any state of mind which our masters
choose to call disease can be treated as
crime and compulsorily cured
it will be vain to plead that states of
mind which displease government need not
always involve moral turpitude and do
not therefore always deserve forfeiture
of liberty
that's one
great
and
second again from c.s lewis this very
kindness stings with intolerable insult
to be cured against one's will and
curative states which we may not regard
as disease is to be put on a level of
those who have not yet reached the age
of reason or those who never will to be
classed with infants imbeciles and
domestic animals
they certainly are
infantilizing us
and or
we are allowing our infantilization
and
um
i would say they are
infantilizing us
they are gaslighting us
they are
intimidating us and that different
things work on different people
but that at some level
they will do whatever it takes to make
sure
that we are denied
all choice
that we are left with one option and
that we are
unpersoned should we find that
unacceptable
and
i think the thing is anybody who does
that is obviously
the definition of the wrong side of
history we know that these people are
bad however they became that way because
of their insistence on robbing us of all
all options
all agency
um and and all reason and you know how
much do you need to know about
people like that before you realize
actually i'm not listening to them
anymore i'm with the people who are
making sense
how do we explain i i don't think this
is a non-sequitur although it may sound
like it and you and i have not discussed
this at all actually it hasn't come up
between us yet
how do you explain the number of just
blatant inaccuracies
um from scotus in the description of the
the
possible mandates the supreme court of
the united states specifically i think
kagan and sotomayor
um
had some just whoppers in there and i
and
i didn't watch very much i didn't see
that many transcripts either but my
sense is i may be wrong um that they
believe what they're saying yeah oh boy
they
they really believe what they're saying
and
wow like what then what do we what do we
do
well i think
i mean i really think it comes down to
this
you know you called them whoppers
we might call them whoppers
from wapo
uh from the washington post you know and
i think i think the thing is look
let's
let's be kind
to our supreme court justices these
people
live in a very visible position at the
head of officialdom
and
those in officialdom
for reasons that we would have to guess
that probably can't afford
to
entertain things that they are being
told
are fringe and misinformation or
disinformation
dangerous
and so i think the point is if you're
spooked enough because your position
does not allow you to engage these
things
you reject them every time they show up
on a screen and you basically are
constantly reasserting that you are not
uh from
the crazy
tribe nor do you listen to them and if
that's your bent because your job
demands it
then
what we're talking about is like a
foreign language and so in some sense
this was like a
an exploration
of
the party line mind right people who
have never trafficked in doubt about the
public health authorities and are
therefore effectively
reverse engineering what must be behind
their proclamations but i guess so this
i've already been surprised and stunned
and beyond disappointed by a lot of
people these last two years
who
can question stories when they come
in a domain that they have at least
passing familiarity with
and we have long noticed and talked
about on dark horse but for decades have
noticed
how
much more easily people would put faith
in a proclamation it becomes numbers
or it comes with an imprimatur of a
scientific authority
because most people are so badly
educated in math and in science in
school that they have long since said
that i black box that i have to choose
the people i listen to
and if they think that the
current government is one that is
uh you know legitimately working on
their behalf then they will look to the
authorities the government has appointed
that's devastating and is doing
tremendous damage across
across media let's let's say
it is precisely the job of the supreme
court of the united states
to
have doubt on every subject
i feel like you know i don't i am
i am no legal scholar in any way but i
feel like that is actually a reasonable
claim to being one of their top
priorities
yeah but
i mean i i think you're on the right
track here
everybody is being
bullied away from their professional
responsibilities
right we are firing doctors and nurses
who as doctors and nurses are not
compelled
that these vaccines are
safe and effective enough to take right
we are
intimidating doctors who talk
about alternative treatments that they
have tried and have gotten value from
so the point is everybody you and i are
supposed to not do what you and i do
right we're trained to look into complex
systems and to understand them even in
light of imperfect evidence that's what
evolutionary biologists do we we never
have randomized controlled trials we're
always dealing with data sets that are
confusing and imperfect and deeply
incomplete
and so
you know we're not supposed to be doing
that now why because this is that kind
of emergency
well what i don't remember
is the discussion that says where is the
threshold right
we all agree that there are
circumstances so dangerous that your
normal instincts should be put on hold
right we all agree with that right if
the ship is sinking
then that is the priority
what we have not discussed is
okay at least the initial variants of
sars cov2
were worse than the flu
how much worse than the flu does
something have to be
before you turn
society upside down before you allow
small businesses to be destroyed and all
of that wealth transferred to their
gigantic competitors how bad does
something have to be before we suspend
normal and the answer is we pass stuff
around all the time in a normal year
people are passing flu to each other
grandmothers are dying because somebody
gets on a plane you shouldn't right this
happens all the time
now maybe
the point is we should have a very
different approach to all infectious
disease and it should affect travel but
we've never had that conversation that
we were just simply told that this
pathogen was above some threshold where
we needed to turn the world upside down
and effectively to do it indefinitely
until when
we don't know they've never told us who
are we apparently that's not ours to
know and so
you've got supreme court justices
not behaving like supreme court justices
you've got members of congress not
behaving like members of congress you've
got presidents not behaving like
presidents you've got professors not
behaving like professors you've got
philosophers not doing philosophy right
everybody is failing in their
professional responsibilities because
something is forcing them out of it and
those of us who have attempted to
continue to do what we do have found
ourselves in
this weird
netherworld where
we are portrayed as the enemies of
reason and decency and health and you
know okay that's why right you're in a
world where the doctors who are doing
the doctoring are now heretics and the
professors who are continuing to try to
do the job of sorting stuff out are you
know
dangerous conspiracy theorists or
whatever and the answer is look either
you're smart enough to see through that
and to say wait a second maybe those are
the doctors i should be listening to
or you're not and
i guess i'm not terribly surprised that
the supreme court
is um staffed by people who have not
figured their way out of the matrix
because they live at the center of it
yeah
i think you're right
it doesn't um
it doesn't breed confidence though does
it oh boy no it don't terrify us
but you know it's also i think many
people are
sort of groping for you know they're
asking well
what will end this
right
how is this going to end if this is
where we are and the answer is
it's not going to be easy but
so many things come down to the same
calculation that a smoker ought
to have right the fact that what you
face to quit smoking is very very
difficult is no argument whatsoever to
not quit smoking it's an argument to do
it now because it's only going to get
worse
yeah so that's where we are the point is
what's going to end this
well
it's going to be us finally facing it
together and saying no right that's
what's going to end it when would be a
good time to do that uh i'm trying to
remember what the aphorism is
something like uh the best time
to do it would have been
two years ago the second best time is
now right
it's that
[Music]